it's everything I've always wanted to do
I've always been passionate about space
and science and it's a great opportunity
to do science communication and
contribute to science one way is
currently the only way that we can get
to Mars on the kind of Bridget that we
we've got available in the next ten
years what are your friends and family
say about that they are surprisingly
supportive and proud and they've been
sending me like so many messages over
the past couple of days congratulating
me and like it's just been really lovely
dr. ghavami do you think that Maggie or
indeed anyone else is actually going to
get as far as miles on this mission do I
think that anyone's going to get as far
as Mars well it's really difficult to
say actually because yes the technology
is there but the timescales that the
Mars one mission is talking about just
doesn't seem feasible to land human
beings on the surface of Mars in 2024
I'm really sorry but I just don't
imagine how that could be possible
Maggie Lu what do you make of it I mean
the details are a bit vague about this
mission aren't they I think there are
like the available technologies to get
us there I mean the last missions to the
moon were in the 70s so we've had space
technology available for years and it's
more about the funding rather than the
technology available say yeah what
details have you been given I mean are
you perhaps a little bit worried in a
corner of your mind that this is a
publicity stunt or hoax some kind
so I've done a lot of research on it
already and part of the selection
process was actually a Mars test like
learning about how previous Mars
missions had failed or six were
successful owning about their geology
and geography so it's been really
interesting that's gadani is it always
going to be within feasible science a
one-way trip to get to Mars if you leave
from Earth well not not really I mean
sort of NASA were planning trips to Mars
for human beings and they are planning
return missions they're just not trying
to do it on a shoestring crowdfunded and
within the next ten years and I think
that's the key thing Maggie mentioned
the funding which is hopefully going to
be through sort of TV and media and
merchandising and crowdfunding and six
billion sounds like a lot of money but
it really isn't to get human beings to
land safely on Mars and that's part of
the problem with it being this one-way
one-way ticket I mean if we just wait a
little bit longer and talk about it a
bit more and get a bit more knowledge
about how to get them back and a bit
more money then it couldn't it doesn't
have to be this one-way mission which is
so ethically and morally questionable
because I mean maybe what you're
contemplating is effectively a suicide
mission isn't it I mean it's the rest of
your life and all the other things you
might look forward to in life given up
on this journey to Mars I don't really
see it as a suicide mission I see it as
a way to leave a legacy and a huge
impact on mankind and the general public
and I don't know I think it's really
important to inspire the future
generations to be interested in science
and about like not coming back
in the astronauts that go to the ISS for
like six or seven months when they come
back there they're not able to walk
again because of the effects of gravity
on their bodies so even if I go to Mars
for a long period of time I might not
actually want to come back knowing that
I would never be able to walk again
kimagure if you heard about this expert
to estimate that apparently crew to
arrive on the planet Mars would not
survive longer than 70 days and if so
would you make of this yeah so I've
actually read the paper is really
interesting it's a study done by MIT and
it's about regulating the amount of
oxygen that we produce waltz were up
there so at the moment the technology
isn't available to vent the oxygen to
get the right balance like similar to
the air that we breathe on earth and so
after about 60 days there would be a
huge risk of fire however we've got 10
years to get this technology moving and
20 years ago most people didn't like
believe in mobile phones and we rely on
it's so much nowadays so nothing's
impossible that's canale do you think
whether or not Maggie goes to Mars in
the interest of humanity that this is
the future of the race really
interplanetary travel and getting out
into space is what we've got to do as
human beings I I do believe that
planetary exploration is highly highly
significant and important for the future
of the human race but I'm just not sure
that this is the way to do it yes we do
want to inspire the next generation of
scientists and engineers and we're doing
that anyway look at the Rosetta mission
look at finding beagle to just a month
or so ago we're doing that anyway and
the UK have got such a brilliant impact
and such a brilliant Space Agency coming
up through the generations now that
maybe this isn't the way to inspire the
next generation